mag es schon wieder unterwegs australien
wo ist die biener da ich würde auch gern
mal wieder nur war ich das letzte mal
nicht essen ein esel
[Musik]
fear of missing out kurz vor
so nennt man die angst etwas zu
verpassen die angst dass deine freunde
ohne die spaß haben vielleicht sogar
mehr spaß als wenn du dabei wäre es die
angst dass auf einer party wie du
verpasst der schick passiert über den
fall reden und du dich mit reden kannst
das phänomen ist in unserer generation
so präsent geworden dass es sich einige
psychologen zum forschungsthema erklärt
haben allen voran der psychologe philipp
brixius kinski der folgenden
psychologischen evaluations bogen
namensform muss gegenentwurf erstes ich
habe angst dass andere tolle sachen
erleben als ich 21 ich habe angst dass
meine freunde tollere sachen erleben als
ich ins ich mache mir einen kopf wenn
meine freunde ohne mich spaß haare die
hinten ich krieg die krise wenn ich
nicht weiß was meine freunde gerade tun
es ist mir wichtig insider witz in
meiner freunde zu verstehen sechs
manchmal frage ich mich ob ich zu viel
zeit damit verbringen immer auf dem
laufenden zu sein
ich finde es schlimm wenn ich eine
gelegenheit verpasste meine freunde
zutrifft achten wenn ich spaß habe oder
eine tolle erfahrung machte dann möchte
ich die auch online teilen 9 und wenn
ich ein geplantes treffen verpasste dann
stört mich das ziemlich tetens wenn ich
im urlaub bin halte ich mich auf dem
laufenden über das was meine freunde zu
hause machen wenn ihr dem großteil
dieser aussagen stark zustimmt dann
leidet die wahrscheinlich an foto ich
habe euch den fragebogen unten auch noch
mal verlinkt da könnt ihr euch zum spaß
testen eine korrekte wissenschaftliche
auswertung ist da aber nicht dabei genau
diese fragen aber werden in
psychologischen studien immer wieder
verwendet um das ausmaß der foto
festzuhalten psychologen sind sich einig
vor und social media hören ganz klar
zusammen
früher war es ja auch gar nicht so
leicht herauszufinden was die freunde
ständig
machen heute geht man nicht nur täglich
damit konfrontiert sondern natürlich
stellt wie es jeder auf social media
besonders toller einstieg bläst ich
interessant wie sich die zeiten ändern
bei meiner recherche hierfür bin ich auf
eine studie von 1998 gestoßen
die internetsucht mit depressionen in
verbindung es hieß damals wussten sie
noch nicht was internetsucht wirklich
ist seit es sie gibt muss man
internetsucht wirklich neu definieren
[Musik]
früher konnte man an einem samstagabend
in jogginghose auf der couch sitzen und
sein leben genießen
heute sitzt und an samstag abends auf
der couch mit einem schlechten gewissen
weil alle freunde anscheinend ein viel
spannendes leben haben als man selbst es
ist noch nicht ganz klar ob social media
vorwurf vorantreibt oder oktober die
nutzung von social media verstärkt was
denkt ihr schreibt in die kommentare von
drew ist jedenfalls analog zu sozialer
ausgrenzung und hass so schlimm ist das
wissen neurologen die haben nämlich
beobachtet dass bei sozialer ausgrenzung
dieselben gehirnregionen aktiviert
werden wie man physischer schmerz
außerdem wurde vor mit einem geringeren
selbstbewusstsein geringerer
selbstzufriedenheit und einem allgemein
schlechteren gemütszustand in verbindung
gebracht was kann man jetzt dagegen
machen wenn ihr tipps habt schreibt in
die kommentare wir jedenfalls machen
jetzt zwei wochen sommerpause und die
sind dann am 17 august möglich da das
heißt die nächsten zwei wochen könnt ihr
zumindest auf diesem kanal nichts
verpassen
berührt oder schlau wie schlimm ist eure
foto macht den tisch legen wie gesagt in
der beschreibung und schreit mir euren
score mein score ist 630 hat keine
besonders ausgeprägte kommune zum glück
wir wie gesagt nach der sommerpause in
zwei wochen
bis dahin bleibt sicher